salafi what what that you could pack a
lot
into fitna right that yeah but for the
for those who have no clue what you're
talking about right now give us a
general idea of what that would include
well fitna can be uh a past station from
islam
outright where you say i i'm muslim i no
longer a muslim
muslim i renounce his life wallahi
i tell you this the beginning of ramadan
in 2008 came
and i got a text message from a friend
of mine
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
that you could pack a lot into fitna
right yeah
but for though for those who have no
clue what you're talking about right now
give us a general idea of what that
would include
well fitna can be uh apostation from
islam
outright where you say i i'm muslim i no
longer are muslim
muslim i renounce islam but you can
apostate from islam
by denying anything that's cardinal to
islam
like the the the nature of the koran
the five pillars of islam um some of the
uh cardinal rules of islam like wearing
the hijab or kemar
um being modest praying five times a day
so if you say i don't believe in that or
even if you just don't do it
i believe in it but i just don't do it
that's fitna also
all of that is fitna so all of that
according to the quran and the god of
the quran
is worse than murder wallahi
i tell you this the beginning of ramadan
in 2008 came
and i got a text message from a a friend
of mine
brother abu zakaria i'm giving him
credit
abu zakaria he sent me a text message
and a ted's is this is this
or is it this is a different this is a
different brother
okay he sent me a text message and he
said assalamu alaikum
are you ready to come back home i hadn't
heard from this brother in years
and i heard this i haven't spoken to him
hadn't
received a text message we hadn't had
any communication in years
at that point in my life which coincided
with the beginning of ramadan
he sends me a text message asking are
you ready to come back home
and you know i you know i was being a
smart
smart button not sent back are you ready
to accept jesus as your lord and savior
and so uh we started talking you know
and we started talking and
i just found it weird that those things
coincided with each other at the same
exact time
and i really started thinking
well if you're open-minded enough to
explore
everything you say that you want to see
the proof
for everything you want to see the
evidence for everything
where you uh take a look and to see
whether or not
it was a mistake to leave islam are you
willing to go that far
and i really thought about that
it was part of a part of me that
resisted that
and it got to the point where
i would wake up in the morning and i
would go into the bathroom
and i would look in the mirror and i
couldn't look at my
own reflection in the mirror
i couldn't look into my own eyes
i knew something okay
okay i'll look into it how about that
i'll look into it
i'll at least explore the idea
so i started going i went to a masjid
and i would just first day i just wanted
to sit
and observe not watch the brothers may
so long
then after doing that a few times the
i started i got into a conversation with
the imam
well he another brother that i knew
from back in the days he just happens to
be at the masjid
you know and
we started talking so i'm now i'm
talking to the brother of rhea tetz that
i had spoken to in years
talking to this other brother hadn't
seen in years and speaking to the the
local imam at the master
and i'm going to the master this is all
doing ramadan
and it was like my heart it was on
it was if if you had a heart covered in
steel
and some and you poured acid
and it melted the steel down so you got
to the fleshy part of the heart
that that's what it was like the
hardness
against the hardness that was inside me
towards the idea of islam and returning
even returning to islam it began to just
slowly melt away
day by day each day in ramadan it just
melted away
seeing the brothers made salah just like
wow
i remember that i remember what that was
like